foreign
foreign
foreign
I have been requested to brief you on
article 100 of the charter I will do so
and also address the context in which
this request has come about by
clarifying the nature of the work
performed by the Secretary General and
the Secretariat with respect to
resolution 20 to 31 2015.
article 7 paragraph 1 of the charter
establishes the Secretariat as one of
the six principal organs of the United
Nations article 97 provides that the
Secretariat shall comprises Secretary
General and such staff as the
organization may require
article 100 sets out obligations for the
Secretary General and the staff of the
Secretariat in the conduct of their work
and corresponding obligations on the
part of member states vis-a-vis the
Secretariat
the article has been frequently
described as the foundation of the idea
of the Secretariat as an international
civil service
thus paragraph 1 defines the status of
the Secretary General and the staff and
sets out their attendant legal
obligations
specifically the Secretary General and
the staff are international officials
responsible only to the organization
they must not seek or receive
instructions from any government or from
any other authority external to the
United Nations
and they must I quote refrain from any
action which might reflect on their
position as International officials
responsible only to the organization end
quote
with a view to safeguarding the
international character and Independence
of the Secretariat the general assembly
has laid down detailed standards of
conduct for staff members based directly
on article 100 paragraph one of the
charter
since they were first adopted by the
general assembly in 1951 the staff
regulations like the provisional staff
regulations before them have affirmed in
their very first provision for key ideas
that members of the Secretariat are
international civil servants
that their responsibilities are not
National but exclusively International
that they must discharge their functions
and regulate their conduct with the
interests of the United Nations only in
View and that they shall not seek or
accept instructions in regard to the
performance of their duties from any
government or other source external to
the organization
paragraph two is the counterpart to
paragraph one
it sets out two corresponding
obligations on the part of member states
to respect the exclusively International
character of the responsibilities of the
Secretary General and the staff and not
to seek to influence them in the
discharge of their responsibilities
um
the general assembly has not adopted any
decision specifically relating to this
paragraph that might throw much light on
its interpretation
it has referred to it in connection with
appeals to all member states to respect
the Privileges and the immunities of
officials of the United Nations and to
allow the Secretary General to exercise
the organization's right of functional
protection in respect of Staff placed
under arrest or detention
beyond that though the assembly has not
given any specific guidance on the
application of the paragraph
the Secretary General and the legal
counsel on the header hand boasts my
predecessors and myself
have on a number of occasions taken the
position that these or that action on
the part of a member state is or is not
consistent with its obligations pursuant
to article 100 of the charter
does
they have expressed The View that it
would not or might not be consistent
with paragraph two of that article for a
state
to attempt to make the recruitment
transfer dismissal of Staff of its
nationality subject to its approval
to limit the recruitment of locally
recruited staff to individuals
recommended by a government agency
to impose conditions on the engagement
of locally recruited staff members
to limit the appointment of Staff of its
nationality to fixed term appointments
to pressure the Secretary General to
replace a qualified and competent staff
member because of a change of government
in their home to require the Secretary
General to adapt the contracts of
locally recruited staff to confirm to
its National labor laws
to cancel the work permit of a staff
member in an apparent attempt to force
the Secretary General to dismiss them
to withhold a staff member's passport so
they could not return to their Duty
station or to not issue a passport to a
success successful candidate so as to
prevent them from taking up their post
to require a staff member deployed to
that state to leave the country to
demand the right to censor U.N materials
to assume the power to dictate or
control the activities of United Nations
officials or United Nations operations
to inspect or control the award of
United Nations contracts and to record
they refuse to recognize the Secretary
General as Secretary General
conversely the Secretary General and
legal counsel have taken the position
that it would not been consistent with
paragraph 2 or voting article 100 for a
state to submit to the Secretary General
information on the character and record
of candidates of its nationality
provided that it was understood that it
was left to the Secretary General to
assess that information and reach an
independent decision on their
recruitment
to investigate staff members of its
nationality and provide information on
the outcome of the investigation to the
Secretary General
and to provide the Secretary General
with its views on how the Secretary
General should exercise political
discretion that he may enjoy in
implementing a mandate from one of the
organization's political organs
it is only natural as a previous
Secretary General has remarked that
member states should wish to exercise as
much influence as they can over the
activities of the organization including
its Secretariat most days permanent
Representatives contact the Secretary
General and that the senior officials to
inform them of the positions of their
governments and to seek to convince them
of their rightness I myself frequently
receive visits from ambassadors who
Advance a particular view of the law and
try to convince me that it is correct or
who remonstrate me over a particular
action on the part of the Secretariat
and seek to convince me that it is
unlawful and it's to stop
throughout my mandate I have had
exchanges with all the ambassadors of
the permanent five members of the
security Council all of this is to be
expected and I do not think that anyone
here would wish to maintain that such
activities are in any way inconsistent
with article 100 paragraph 2 of the
charter
as a previous holder of the office once
remarked
the Secretary General knows very well
that his Effectiveness in most
situations will depend to a large extent
on the cooperation that he receives from
governments and in turn that the extent
of that cooperation will frequently
depend at least to some degree on how
far it does coincides with the positions
of those governments but as he also
remarked I quote the Secretary General
must also insist that his duty under the
charter requires him to draw a clear
line between cooperation and pressure
and of quote
Mr President distinguished
Representatives
I will now turn to the work performed by
the Secretary General and the
Secretariat with respect to resolution
20 to 31 of 2015.
without deviating in any way from the
standards that article 100 requires the
secretarial and member states to adhere
to the Secretariat takes note of all
information that is brought to his
attention by member states in order to
add certain and assess its relevance to
the discharge of the mandates that are
entrusted to it
it was in this spirit and in a water
that and the Secretary General Rosemary
DeCarlo noted in her remarks to the
council during its informal
consultations on the 19th October that
the Secretariat was ready to assess
information if so requested by member
states as was also the case for the
spokesperson in his remarks of the 20th
October
following the adoption by the security
Council of resolution 2231 on the 20th
July 2015
the president of the security Council
issued a note dated 16 January 2016 and
procedures for the security Council for
carrying out tasks related to the
implementation of resolution
2231
2015-15 particularly with respect to the
provisions specified in paragraphs two
to seven of nxb or to that resolution
end of quote
paragraph six and seven of the notes
request the Secretary General to appoint
the security Council Affairs division of
what is now the department of political
and peace building Affairs to serve as a
point of contact and support the work of
the security Council and of its
facilitator and as envisaged by nxb to
resolution 20 to 31 to report to the
council every six months on the
implementation of the resolution
paragraph 7 of the note
anticipates that the report will include
findings and recommendations and that
the security Council will meet
informally prior to the public release
of the report to review the findings and
recommendations it contains
the Secretary General duly acted on
these requests and the security Council
Affairs division has prepared the
reports starting with this first report
issued on the 12th July 2016 and the
symbol s slash 2016 589
the most recent 13 report was issued on
the 23rd June this year under the symbol
s slash 20 2022-490.
the structure of these reports and the
topics addressed are well known to the
council in this regard I note that in
his statement to the council introducing
the first report
and the Secretary General for political
Affairs Jeffrey Feldman pointed out that
I quote this report strictly focuses on
the restrictive measures in nxb of
resolution 2231 2015 our mandate is
neither to report on all aspects of the
resolution or Annex a of the gcpoa nor
touch upon the work of The Joint
Commission established in the agreement
end of quote
consistently with this the Secretariat
as reported on the implementation of the
restrictive measures in nxb that are
enforced during the reporting period
including on information voluntarily
brought to its attention by member
states in writing and through meetings
at United Nations Headquarters or in
capitals also reflected are the
positions of Interest member states on
such information that have been brought
to the attention of the Secretary
General
as I just mentioned the report includes
findings and recommendations in line
with paragraph 7 of the note
the Secretary General is thus able to
express his views on relevant
developments during the reporting period
and draw attention to matters of concern
as intended the report is entirely for
the information of the security Council
in its consideration of the status of
the implementation of resolution 2231 in
particular nxb and determination whether
any action is required the Secretary
General has not received any request
pursuant to paragraph 6 G of the note or
otherwise that supplements or modifies
the nature and scope of the work done by
the security Council Affairs division in
the preparation of the secretary
General's six monthly reports to the
council
further guidance by the security Council
the Secretary General will continue to
prepare these reports in the manner that
they have been prepared to date thank
you
exposure
ments
um
declaration
representative
examples
foreign
Rich dude
as a documentation is
Stadium
foreign
instructions
Stadium
foreign
foreign
consensus
is
foreign
Michelin
practice
Associated resolution
website
is
accidentally
Shooters
organizations findings
is
conclusion
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
secretary
foreign
foreign
United States
uh thank you Mr President and thank you
under Secretary General uh Miguel de
surpris Suarez for your briefing
the claim Russia is making is
dumbfounding simply dumbfounding
once again Russia has wasted the
security council's time to deflect
attention from its own egregious
wrongdoing
Russia claims that requests from the
United States and other countries that
the Secretary General investigate
Russia's and Iran's violations of U.N
security Council resolution 2231 are a
supposed violation of article 100 of the
charter
article 100 provides the I quote the
Secretary General and the staff shall
not seek or receive any instructions
from any government unquote
the requests of the United States and
other council members were not
instructions
they similar to countless other requests
made to the Secretary General by UN
member states were requests that he take
appropriate action
many member states make requests like
this to the Secretary General including
Russia
indeed as recently as August of this
year Russia requested that the Secretary
General investigate killings at a prison
in eastern Ukraine
Secretary General in response to this
request decided to conduct a
fact-finding mission
far from constituting instructions to
the Secretary General such requests for
investigations are common appropriate
and by no means in violation of article
100 of the UN Charter
but this situation is even more
clear-cut given the unique language and
mandate in Security Council resolution
2231
his colleagues will recall this
important resolution was adopted in July
2015
as the Iran nuclear deal was finalized
it established critical restrictions on
Iran that would last for a period of
years
all council members including Russia
voted for it
Russia was involved in negotiating its
provisions
in this case Russia and Iran teamed up
to violate resolution 2231.
Iran in violation of resolution 2231
provided Russia with drones to wreak
havoc and inflict destruction on
Ukrainian civilians
Russia in violation of resolution 2231
procured them
Iran has been open and vocal about its
support
and there is no doubt that the transfer
occurred without approval by the council
and thus in violation of resolution
2231.
Security Council itself asked the
Secretary General to play a vital role
reporting on violations of this
resolution
it is therefore well within the
authority of the Secretary General to
investigate Russia's and Iran's
violations of resolution 2231.
that resolution explicitly asked the
Secretary General to report every six
months on the implementation of that
resolution's provisions
at the time it was adopted and in the
seven years since
council members have understood this
mandate to include investigations of
alleged violations of that resolution
typically following reports of concerns
by member states
in fact
there is ample precedent for the U.N
Secretariat to carry out independent
investigations as part of this mandate
to report on implementation
over the past seven years the Secretary
General has submitted to the security
Council 13 reports summarizing its
investigations and findings on
non-compliance
for example
in the report contained in s slash
2017-1030
the Secretary General reported on an
investigation of allegations that
Iranian supplied ballistic missiles were
used by the houthis in attacks against
Saudi Arabia
Secretary General reported on a visit to
Saudi Arabia examination of the weapons
debris and other investigative
investigative actions taken by the
Secretariat in response to the
allegations
more recently
in response to an invitation from the
authorities of Saudi Arabia the
secretary had traveled to Riyadh in
October 2021 to examine the debris from
six ballistic missiles tied to the
houthi attacks
the Secretariat's team also went to
Israel in 2021 to inspect Iranian uavs
that had infiltrated Israeli airspace
in each of these cases crucially
the secretary General's report did not
just consist of verbatim repetition of
allegations of violations of resolution
2231 and or assertions of denials of the
Same by member states
instead the secretary engaged in its own
investigations in order to evaluate the
allegations so that it could report as
it is mandated to do
on the extent to which the alleged
violations impacted the implementation
of resolution 2231 by member states
it is thus well established that it is
well within the authority of the
Secretary General to investigate
allegations of violations of resolution
2231.
the United States and other requests
that the Secretary General investigate
the latest violations by Iran and Russia
were appropriate and urgently needed
Russia's response
that the Ukraine report should be
treated differently and that the U.N
leadership should block the
investigations typically undertaken in
these cases is deeply troubling and
inconsistent with years of this
council's practice
now we see Russia making threats against
the United Nations
for reasons that are obvious to all
Russia seeks to obstruct and confuse
but yielding to these threats
and acceding to Russia's demand that the
Secretariat not carry out its 22-31
mandate in this instance would be
extremely problematic
it would undermine implementation of U.N
security Council resolutions and give
all countries including Russia a free
pass to flout Security Council imposed
obligations
the United States regrets that Russia
has once again abused its position as a
council member to waste this body's time
and seek to hide its own violations of
our resolutions thank you Mr President
to the representative of India
thank you Mr President I will be brief
let me Begin by thanking USD for legal
Affairs for this briefing
India appreciates the important work of
the U.N Secretariat in supporting the
security Council
we value the periodic reports of the
Secretary General to the security
Council and the professional work that
goes behind the preparation of such
reports
in preparing these reports the
Secretariat should always be guided by
the Mandate provided in the council's
resolution
presidential statements and notes of the
president
in the current context para 7 of note 44
of 2016 by the security Council
president clearly requested the
Secretary General to report to the
security Council every six months on the
implementation of resolution 2231
we hope that the Secretariat will
continue to objectively function on such
issues and undertake its activities in
accordance with the Mandate provided by
this Council
respect for provisions of the U.N
Charter is an absolute must I thank you
representation
thank you Mr President and I also thank
you Jesus for its pertinent
clarifications
the reason that of the sectorate is to
execute its mandate with objectivity and
impartiality without fear or favor and
that involves also reminding states of
their obligations and the degree to
which they adhere to them
impartiality doesn't mean indifference
Detachment from reality when commitments
are not upheld and when the law is
broken this is why we strongly value the
work
of the sectorate in their attempts to
ensure consistency and continuity in the
application of the uncharter in the
service of all member states without
distinctions
this is why we rightly expect all states
to respect these prerogatives and
cooperate in good faith with the secret
threats against it are unconscionable
and further profess the total disregard
of the rules that underpin our
organization
the secret should not yield to such
threats
equally member states should not heed
any demands that may prevent them from
carrying their duties in discharging
their obligations including on the
master at hand the monitoring mandate
for resolution 2231
this would create a dangerous president
it would undermine the implementation of
the United Nations security Council
resolutions and create the impression
that some countries can disregard
obligations at will and with impunity
Mr President we all know to read the
rules and the charter and what we have
adopted but that's not the key issue
let's come to the core issue which is
the denial that Russia has deployed
iran-made uavs against civilian
structure infrastructure in Ukraine
which as we know are wrecking havoc on
killing civilians
if what Russia says is the truth if it
has nothing to hide if it is
implementing Security Council
resolutions upholding the charger and it
is respecting international law although
the general assembly thinks that is not
the case then in the interest of the
truth and Clarity Russia must be the
first to welcome an independent and
impartial verification to bring the
truth to light
welcome it and not threatened mandate
holders and the first of them the
Secretary General
in 19 in 2015 the council adopted
resolution 2231 to endorse the Iran
nuclear deal and keep in place certain
critical restrictions for a period of
years on Iran the resolution asked the
Secretary General to and I quote report
to the security Council on the
implementation of these Provisions every
six months and it was amply
mentioned by the legal advisor with the
adoption of the resolution the security
Council fully supported the sectorate in
establishing a team and a process to
monitoring his implementation and member
states have supported through years the
unsectorate
2231 team by providing information and
Analysis as mentioned by the legal
advisor in the last seven years the
Secretary General has done so it has
submitted 13 reports summarizing his
investigations and findings on report of
non-compliance based on many visits and
inspections by the 2231 team
and your delegation mentioned but I want
to mention again myself as well so in
December 21 the Secretary General
recalled the sector's visit it was a
sectored visit to Saudi Arabia to
examine the breeze of six ballistic
missiles from the houthis the Secretary
of team went also to Israel in 2021 to
inspect Iranian uavs that are
infiltrated Israel airspace how these
cases are different from the Iran
produced uavs that are being used today
in by Russia in Ukraine
Mr President a member State Ukraine has
submitted a request to the president of
the security Council based on its own
evidence that Russia has used uavs of
Iranian production and origin whose
transfer is clearly prohibited by
2231 resolution reliable sources have
shown Russia is using those uavs
including a civilian infrastructure in
Ukraine such procurements and transfers
are a clear violation of paraphor
Phoenix B offers the resolution and two
member states Russia and Iran are in
clear breach of that resolution this is
why we reiterate our call to the
secretary to do its job and not get lost
in intentionally confusing semantics
when its mandate is clear organized
visits insights which Ukraine has
offered to facilitate collect evidence
and report about its findings following
its well-established procedure the UN
2231 team should analyze the available
evidence evidence in partially and
report its findings to the security
Council and we look forward to that
report and I thank you
to the representative of France
[Music]
deeply regrets the cynicism Charter
Russia that has not stopped
the charter and running the principles
of the church
foreign
against civilian targets
unanimously by myself
in similar circumstances
one
the Russian representative affirmed on
the 19th of October
his question were Russian drones
with the United Nations
to the representative of Ireland
thank you president and I would like to
thank the under Secretary General for
his very useful briefing today President
we welcome Ukraine's invitation for the
U.N Secretariat to visit Ukraine to
inspect recovered uavs with regards to
the implementation of resolution 2231 by
parties and expect the Secretariat to
keep the council informed as appropriate
on this matter
we see this request by a state with
legitimate concerns regarding the
implementation of resolution 2231 as
fully in keeping with both the U.N
Charter and the terms of resolution 2231
and note 44.
note 44 clearly sets out that the
Secretary General should report on the
implementation of resolution 2231 every
six months and for the council in 2231
format to review his findings and
recommendations
the necessary technical investigations
that the Secretariat conducts are an
integral part of preparing these
findings no further decision by the
council is necessary in this regard
the secretary General's reports play an
essential role in assisting the council
in its mandated task to monitor the
implementation of the resolution and to
take action as appropriate to improve
the implementation by member states of
the resolution
president with regards to article 100 of
the UN Charter unfortunately it is
Russia that is seeking to influence the
Secretary General and staff in the
discharge of their responsibilities
including through this meeting
it is clear that the Secretariat is
acting in good faith on the instructions
that the council has given it if these
instructions are to change this must be
agreed by the council in line with Note
44 and cannot be dictated by any one
member I hope that Russia will cooperate
as necessary with the Secretariat in the
conduct of its work and provide any
information required to clarify these
issues regarding the implementation of
resolution 2231 thank you
of Ghana thank you Mr President I joined
previous delegations in thanking USG Mr
sepas Suarez for his briefing and for
clarifying the role of the United
Nations Secretariat in relation to the
implementation of Security Council
resolution 2231.
our Russian colleagues have suggested
that the joint request by France Germany
and the United Kingdom for an
investigation by the Secretariat's team
responsible for the monitoring and
implementation of resolution 2231 into
the reported transfer from Iran to the
Russian Federation of unmanned aerial
Vehicles being used in Ukraine
constitutes a violation of the United
Nations Charter Ghana is fully
supportive of the objectives of 2231
which has as it's called the protection
of all Humanity from the dangers of
nuclear capacities we therefore urge
full compliance with its provisions and
support the investigations of any
violations through appropriate channels
the issues that present us that
presently confront us however is the
continuing aggression of the Russian
Federation against Ukraine and the
imperatives for the reversal of such
action
we continue to be deeply concerned by
the Russian federation's unjustified
invasion of the Sovereign territory of
Ukraine its targeted attacks against
civilians and the deliberate destruction
of Civilian and critical infrastructure
in violation of the principles of
international law and the values and
purposes of the charter of the United
Nations
[Music]
by the Russian Federation and its
subsequent wielding of the veto in a
manner that has so far restrained
requested Council action that cast out
on our ability to deliver on the mandate
to promote International Peace and
security as it relates to Ukraine this
is the reality that threatens the peace
and stability of our International
System and regrettably impunes the
Integrity of our organization
we reiterate a call on the Russian
Federation to immediately and
unconditionally withdraw its troops from
the internationally recognized borders
of Ukraine and bring an end to the war
which has not only affected Ukraine and
its people but has also precipitated
unpleasant socio-economic challenges
especially for developing countries like
Ghana
we remain deeply concerned by the
prevailing conditions marked by intense
fighting and heightened rhetoric
relating to the use or threat of use of
various forms of weapons of mass
destruction we are also concerned that
the requirement for nuclear Safety and
Security at the supervision nuclear
power plants are yet to be implemented
we strongly urge restraints and caution
against such rhetoric being used as
justification for any tactical use of
nuclear weapons the precarious
conditions in Ukraine and the tendency
for its rapid escalation highlights the
urgency to intensify diplomatic efforts
to end the hostilities and further help
the parties on a pathway to a Pacific
settlement of the conflict through
dialogue
I closed by reaffirming Ghana's full
support for the sovereignty political
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Ukraine I thank you president
represent of Brazil thank you Mr
President
let me start by thanking USG Serpa
Suarez for the clarifications presented
Brazil takes note of the letters
circulated jointly by the missions of
France Germany and the United Kingdom
s 2022-781
as well as the letters circulated by the
mission of the United States
s 2022-72
and the mission of the Russian
Federation AS Slash 2022-73
the letters draw the attention of
council members to the implementation of
resolution 2231
more particularly the latter circulated
by the Russian Federation refers also to
article 100 of the U.N Charter
it is our understanding that under
presidential Note S
2016-44 paragraph 7 dated 16 January
2016.
Secretary General was mandated to and I
quote report to the security Council
every six months on the implementation
of resolution 2231.
any end quote any further action Beyond
this mandate should be discussed by the
security Council including responding to
information regarding alleged actions
inconsistent with a resolution in
accordance with article 2D of the
presidential note
nonetheless it is worth recalling that
in similar situations in the past the
Secretariat traveled in response to an
invitation from concerned member states
to examine and collect relevant
information for its regular reporting
such was the case described in previous
reports of the Secretary General on the
implementation of resolution 2231
Brazil trusts that the Secretariat will
continue to carry out its mandate
strictly in accordance with Note S 2016
44 and article 100 preserving its
exclusively International character
in an Ever more complex International
Security context the jcpoa provides a
suitable framework for dialogue among
the parties concerned
Brazil counts on the collective
commitment of the gcpoa's original
participants to conclude negotiations
and immediately resume full compliance
with their respective obligations under
the agreement and with resolution 2231
of this Council I thank you
from Norway thank you president
we thank USG Suarez for his briefing
Norway fully supports the Secretariat's
role in implementing resolution 2231
the reported transfer of uavs from Iran
to Russia for use in Ukraine is a great
concern
these drones are used to attack
civilians and civilian objects
this usage is prohibited under
International humanitarian law and may
constitute war crimes the transfer
research uavs would also be a violation
of resolution 2231 and XP paragraph 4.
insecurity Council presidential note of
s
2016-44 paragraph 7 the Secretary
General was requested to report
biannually on the implementation of
resolution 2231 including his findings
and recommendation
in fulfillment of this request the
Secretary General has reported 13 times
to the council many of the findings have
been based on first-hand assessments of
evidence collected on the ground and
many of the assessments have been
initiated based on letters from member
states with information or potential
violations and actions inconsistent with
the provisions contained in resolution
2231 and XB these letters have also
included travel invitations from
relevant authorities in order for the UN
to conduct necessary first-hand
assessments in I in our view there is
nothing about the conduct of the
secretary in connection with the request
put forward in the letter from Ukraine
that could substantiate the Russian
claims of misconduct
let me recall that article 100 of the
U.N Charter requires each member state
of the U.N to respect the impartiality
of the Secretary General and his staff
and not to influence them in the
discharge of their responsibilities
we regret that Russia through accusing
others or violating this principle is in
fact itself disregarding the spirit of
article 100.
this can only be understood as an
attempt to draw attention away from
Russia's own illegal war and actions
thank you
Mexico
gracias president thank you
yes
issues that are relevant to the topic
especially since the inconvenience
for referencing our position on some
aspects of the war which is taking place
in Ukraine and has been eight months
of Geneva of 1949
contains specific Provisions
who are supposed to distinguish between
the civilians
using
U.S
there is no justification
for attacks yeah
residential buildings
infrastructure for basic services or
other civilian targets
to put a stop to these aggressions
for the United Nations
uh manufacturing was possibly
this request
was done after the corresponding legal
analysis
to the provisions
of prevention
representative of China
foreign
100 of their childhood is an important
guarantee of the secretary's
impartiality
duties the secretary
strengthen communication
trust and maintaining unity
and appropriate manner
Mr President
just now
we mentioned about the implementation of
resolution
the main content of the security Council
resolution 2231 is the endorsement of
jcpoa as the current negotiations on
assuming that you're securely
implementation has reached the final
critical stage all parties should
exercise rationality and we've
accurately interpret the provisions
to avoid further complicating the
negotiations on resuming jcpoa
implementation and avoid under one of
the hard one results
China has taken note of the Legends sent
by the to the council by Ukrainian
around Russia France and UK and other
relevant parties under transfer
China has also noted early
faced with clear differences
council members should continue
consultations
clearly how the secretary should be held
out his mandate and avoid History action
that would undermine the unity of the
council I thank you Mr President
representative of the United Arab
Emirates Mr President I thank under
Secretary General for legal Affairs Mr
Miguel de serpasaurus for his briefing
to the security Council today and I'd
like to begin by addressing the most
important element of this discussion for
all of us today the preservation of
article 100 of the UN Charter it is
stating the obvious that the
independence of the Secretariat is
necessary to the proper discharging of
its duties for that very reason article
100 includes the Corolla corollary
obligation on the part of member states
to respect that Independence perhaps
less apparent is how this Independence
is also in the common interest of member
states
fundamentally it's quite simple there
cannot be Sovereign equality of member
states if some whether through Power or
influence are able to instruct the
Secretariat to act or refrain from
acting in a certain manner smaller
states are most acutely aware of the
risk but really it should worry all
states who do not enjoy the privilege of
a permanent Council seat
it would be naive of us to pretend that
member states have never attempted to
exert influence over the Secretariat we
may talk about attempts and even erosion
at times this is why it is so important
today that we reaffirm the fundamental
fundamental nature of article 100 for
the proper functioning of the
Secretariat and the organization as a
whole
second I'd like to address prior
practice in the context of resolution
2231 because non-compliance with
resolution 2231 has implications across
the Middle East impartial documentation
of the resolutions implementation is a
matter of principle for the UAE as is
publicly known we have welcomed the 2231
team of the UN Secretariat to the United
Arab Emirates to inspect the houthis
weapons and their debris or remnants
including most recently following their
terrorist attack on my country on All
Occasions the U.N Secretariat conducted
independent and impartial inspections
which we believe were important to the
findings and recommendations it then
submitted to the security Council
third the discussion today is a reminder
of why Clarity in our decisions and
documents is so important as a member of
the security Council we strive to
establish clear mandates in the
resolutions we negotiate while
constructive ambiguity can facilitate
reaching agreement on difficult issues
language prone to multiple
interpretations or even
misinterpretation can hinder Collective
action clear rules applied equally
Remain the Cornerstone of the
multilateral system thank you Mr
President
of the United Kingdom
thank you Mr President
and I thank the USG for legal Affairs
for his briefing
this this meeting represents another
attempt by Russia to distract from its
crimes in Ukraine
and from Iran and Russia's failure to
abide by their International obligations
Russia and Iran have been caught
red-handed violating resolution 2231.
and Russia is now concocting an argument
about process because they cannot defend
their actions
we have seen them do this many times
before
it is sad that this is now standard
procedure for them
based on the evidence provided by
Ukraine and significant amounts of Open
Source reporting our view is clear
Iran has supplied uavs to Russia
with which Russia is targeting Ukrainian
civilians and civilian infrastructure
and these uavs fall under the list in
Annex B paragraph 4 of un Security
Council resolution 2231
given no prior approval was sought or
granted by the security Council
these transfers represent violations of
22 31.
unlike Russia we are happy for our
position to be verified
we've therefore expressed support for an
impartial expert investigation by the UN
Secretariat in line with its mandate
under 2231
so the facts can be clearly established
household members are aware and as
others have made clear already today
the UN 2231 Secretariat has conducted
many such investigations most recently
in UAE and Saudi Arabia
so this is entirely in line with
precedent and normal practice
Russia's claim we are trying to unduly
influence the Secretariat is both absurd
and hypocritical
it is Russia in trying to sustain its
this information
which first attacked the Secretary
General and now the whole Secretariat
just for doing their jobs
and it is Russia that has threatened to
end all cooperation with the UN if the
Secretariat does not do as Russia wants
that is not the behavior of a country
with nothing to hide that is the
behavior of a bully
colleagues what's Russia trying to do
here today
it is trying to make the un's ability to
monitor implementation of a key
non-proliferation resolution subject to
a new lock in the security Council in
which Russia itself has a veto
Russia again trying to abuse its seat on
the council to Shield itself through
International scrutiny
Mr President further open source
reporting suggests that Iran intends to
transfer yet more uavs and potentially
ballistic missiles to Russia
any such transfers of items could
constitute further violations of
Security Council resolution 2231
and represents a significant escalation
in using Iranian drones to attack
civilians
part of its war on Ukraine Russia is
breaching the U.N Charter is violating a
security Council resolution
and is probably committing war crimes
that is quite the hat trick
these increasingly desperate attempts to
distract us from these facts and
undermine the system must be rejected
thank you
representation
of Kenya
thank you Mr President
and I thank her under Secretary General
Mr Miguel
Suarez for his briefing
I also thank the Russian Federation for
initiating this meeting it provides an
opportunity for member states to assess
the challenges and opportunities of a
strong and independent Secretariat
particularly in regard to the good
offices of the Secretary General
Mr President Humanity needs a strong
independent Secretariat and good
officers of the Secretary General that
are credible and respected they are
needed to intervene to mediate offer
relief in Conflict situations and
emergencies worldwide and to respond to
the Urgent call for development
over time the demand for the secretary
General's good offices whether expressly
provided for such as under security
Council resolution 2646 or through his
own voice have been growing
in regards to the war in Ukraine which
is the reason for today's meeting the
secretary General's good officers were
consequential in achieving the important
black sea green initiative
however they have not been engaged in
negotiations to the end of the war
one of the reasons for this in our view
is the impact of years of member states
questioning the Secretariat's
impartiality and eroding its
independence the most powerful States
including some members of this Council
have played a disproportionate role in
this unfortunate trend
prominent examples of this situation
during our present time on the council
are the claims and counter claims of
compromised impartiality when the
Secretariat is reporting on disarmament
proliferation and banned weapons in
Syria
it appears that there is now a fully
formed view that the Secretariat's
impartiality equals standing on the
halfway line between conflicting parties
however this is not what the charter
means by impartiality instead the
Secretary General and the Secretariat
are an independent organ whose first and
last loyalty is to the upholding and
defense of the charter
Mr President even as we push for Urgent
Security Council reforms we acknowledge
that a more urgent task is the
membership rededicating itself to the
principles of the charter otherwise
multilateralism as expressed in the
United Nations is unlikely to come close
to the meeting to its meeting this
promise
we propose that the most important
starting point is to renew our respect
and utilization of the security sorry of
the secretary General's good officers
for the prevention and resolution of
conflicts and we propose three ways to
strengthen those good offices
the first is to redefine impartiality
and protect the independence of the UN
Secretariat
the reason article 100 protects the
Secretary General and the staff from
external influence or instruction is not
just to be a neutral referee it is to
enable them to speak truth to power in
the defense of the letter and the spirit
of the charter in practice this means
the membership appreciating that the
Secretary General is not partial to a
party in a conflict when he speaks up
about its outrages against the charter
the Secretary General must be fully
partial to the Charter and he should
fully exercise article 99 without regard
for their approval or disapproval of any
state no matter how pivotal in global
affairs
his or her doing so is a duty that
cannot be shocked and therefore his good
officers should not be marginalized from
the mediated settlement of conflicts
this should be the case in regards to
the war in Ukraine or other wars
involving members of this Council
second is the appreciation and use of
the secretary General's fact-finding
capabilities
in order to strengthen the role of the
UN and enhance its Effectiveness in
maintaining International Peace and
security member states adopted
resolution 46 stroke 59 in 1991. the
resolution recognizes the need for the
security Council to have knowledge of
all relevant facts in performing
functions relevant to our mandate
further recognizes the secretary
General's fact-finding capabilities
requires him to monitor the state of
international peace and security for
early warning and share relevant
information with the security Council
making use of the information gathering
capabilities of the Secretariat
the security Council needs to make use
of the reservoir of capabilities under
the Secretary General to contribute to
the effectiveness of our discussions and
decisions
in the situation in Ukraine rather than
argue about the facts on the ground here
in the council where most members have
no independent means to ascertain their
veracity we challenge the conflicting
parties to agree to you and fact-finding
and verification
this would be key to preventing and
minimizing actions contrary to the
Charter and international law
third is on the need to continually
strengthen Regional good offices
article 33 of the charter recognizes the
important role of regional agencies and
Arrangements in dispute resolution
strong Regional mechanisms have
increasingly played a key role in
preventing escalations of conflicts and
determination in the security Council
we are proud of the Africans
Africa peace and security architecture
and its deployment of multi-layered
and coordinated good offices from the
chairpersons of the union and the
commission the panel of the wise and the
regional economic communities it offers
auctions and redundancies in the
protection of peace and security
strengthening the good offices of the
Secretary General and linking them
operationally and strategically to
Africa's improving architecture would be
an immense Win For Peace
we urge other regions to take steps to
develop and deploy similar Regional
arrangements for early warning
prevention and resolution of disputes
finally Mr President
a reaffirm Kenya's commitment to the
purposes and principles of the UN
Charter and our support for Independence
and impartiality of the Secretary
General and his staff thank you
foreign
[Music]
when we heard foreign
persistent objections from members of
the county
consistent
objectories
includes the establishments
from 2016 and we continue to do so today
if we have nothing to hide but the
question
whether somebody is hiding something or
not the question lies in the legitimacy
of such investigation in the absence of
the relevant mandate Security Council
which alone can hand down such a mandate
there is no other mandate Security
Council required
from the coordinator of the 2231 cell
complete legal nihilism
[Music]
they love accusing others of what they
themselves
exhaustive list of violations article
100 of the United Nations
investigations
engage in new violations motivated by
the fact that the violations have
already been committed previously this
is because we are all well familiar with
I wish once again put a question to Mr
swatters to kindly respond to the
question
is
an investigation
constitute a violation of the United
Nations Charter and Provisions of
resolution 20. and will
constitute a breach of the United
Nations Charter thank you
um
[Music]
respond to hypothetical questions thank
you
I think
the additional information
thank you Mr President and distinguished
members of the security Council We join
other states in thanking under Secretary
General for his briefing today
this meeting represents yet another
attempt with the Russian Federation to
distract attention
from its crime of aggression war crimes
and crimes against humanity in our
country
eight and a half years of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine including
eight months of full-scale invasion is a
blatant violation of the end Charter
in this slide
Russia's appeal to the end Charter is
hypocritical cynical
the Russian Federation remains
consistent in its practices of constant
threats and blackmail
this time against the U.N Secretariat
we strongly condemn this unacceptable
pressure and threats to reconsider
cooperation with the UN if the U.N
Secretariat uses their authority to
investigate implementation of this
Security Council resolution
deliberate misuse of the charter
Provisions to impede the investigation
is a clear attempt to put a pressure on
the Secretariat with the aim to avoid
own responsibility
we express our full support to the
Secretary General and the U.N
Secretariat in line with our commitments
under the provisions of the article 100
of the UN Charter
Mr President last Friday Ukraine
informed the council regarding the use
of long-range uavs of Iranian origin by
Russia in its attacks against civilians
and civilian infrastructure in my
country
this represents a blatant violation of
the joint comprehensive plan of action
signed by China France Germany the
United Kingdom the United States the
European Union and Russia itself and
then adopted by the UNSC resolution 2231
of 2015.
that's why as you are aware on 14
October 2022 Ukraine officially
addressed the presidency of the security
Council and requested to start the
relevant independent investigation
in our letter we drew attention to the
alarming situation with respect to the
transfers of mohajar and shahad series
uavs from Iran to Russia specifically in
late August 2022
paragraph 4 of annex B2 resolution 20 to
31 prohibits the transfer from Iran of
all items materials equipment goods and
Technology set out in AS Slash
2015-546 unless approved by the security
Council on a case-by-case basis
Bose mahajar and sahad uavs meet the
parameters of s slash 2015
546 at least under category 2 because
they are capable of a range of equal or
greater than 300 kilometers
further we noted that the mahaja series
uavs is manufactured by quads Aviation
which is subject to the acid freeze
provision of paragraph 6 of annex B2
resolution 2231
all states are required to freeze the
funds of financial assets of designated
entities
according to the information available
no State submitted these shipments for
review by the security Council pursuant
to resolution 2231 and thus they did not
receive Advanced case-by-case approval
as required by nxb to resolution 2231.
Mr President
in using Iranian drones to attack
civilians as well as civilian in
critical infrastructure of Ukraine
Russia is violating the UN Charter
International humanitarian law and the
security Council resolution we see
enough evidence to deem that the
transfers of uavs from Iran to Russia
should be considered
moreover the International Community
should be informed based on the results
of this investigation so we requested
the UN experts to visit Ukraine at the
earliest possible opportunity to inspect
recovered Iranian origin uavs
we believe the findings of the
Secretariat's investigations will
profoundly contribute to assessing
implementation of resolution 2231
the UN investigation should start
immediately
we call on all states to consider any
possible steps to stop this kind of uavs
missile or conventional arms transfers
from Iran to be used in the Russian war
of aggression against Ukraine thank you
of the Islamic Republic of Iran
in the name of God the compassion at the
merciful
I thank you Mr President
for convening this meeting
before I begin
I would like to express my sorrow and
sadness that our people than my country
where today targeted by a terrorist
attack
whereby initial reports the couple of
armed gunmen attacked the holy religious
site known as
Shrine in Shiraz which at least 15
people murdered and injured 21 others
this is a heinous terrorist attack on
civilian including children and women
Iran once again condemns
terrorism in all its forms and
manifestation as a real and graved
terrate to International Peace and
security and it is expected that the
security Council condemn such a heinous
crime explicitly and strongly
Mr President
first and foremost I would like to
clarify and emphasize that Iran's
participation at this meeting
is convened to the matter raised to
relation to resolution 2231
which is directly related to an effect
Iran as a result I feel compelled to
attend this meeting in order to
elaborate on Iran's position on the
claims made against my country in the
context of un Security Council
resolution 2231
Satan Security Council Members including
United States accuse Iran of violating
resolution 2231 despite the fact that
this certain States continue to violate
all the explicit legal obligation under
that same resolution
the main example is
the illegal withdrawal of the United
States from The Joint comprehensive plan
of action which is still openly used as
bargaining leverage today without a
doubt continuing such unlawful Acts
while you're late international law the
United Nations Charter and Security
Council resolution 2231
no in yet another disparate a force
these Estates have attempt to establish
an entirely artificial linkage between
Security Council resolution 2231 and the
use of on manned aerial vehicles in
ongoing conflict in Ukraine by
disseminating unsubstantial and
erroneous information
raising in accurate assumption and
restoring the totally Fallout
arbitrary and misleading interpretation
of that resolution
Mr President let us be clear and
elaborate on Iran's position on
resolution 2231
the claim regarding the violation of
paragraph 4 of nxp to the resolution
2231 is an
erroneous
arbitrary and yet misleading
interpretation that contradiction
contradicts the letter and the spirit of
the paragraph that paragraph clearly
referred to the Restriction of items
materials equipment good and technology
that the state determines could
contribute to the development of nuclear
weapons delivery system
as has been stated in our letter on 19
and 24 October addressed to the security
Council and the Secretary General Iran
has never produced or supplied nor does
it intend to produce or Supply items
materials equipment goods and technology
that could contribute to the development
of nuclear weapons delivery system
with regards to the request of
Secretariat to conduct what is referred
to as an investigation the result the
resolution itself provides no legal
basis for such an investigation
furthermore the president of Security
Council not a dated 16 January
2016. as slash 2016-44
specified the Mandate of Secretariat
regarding the resolution which is only
administrative support the Secretariat
is tasked with assisting the facilitator
in the organization and Staffing of
informal security security council
meeting related to the implementation of
resolution 2231
managing all incoming and outgoing
communication related to the resolutions
implementation drafting correspondence
speaking notes
and briefing of the facilitator related
to the resolutions implementation and
maintaining And archiving all
information and documents relating to
the resolution
having said that that's the president I
would like to emphasize once more that
any misuse of the function described in
the node is slash
2016-44 for conducting the so-called
investigation requested will be illegal
and in clear violation of Secretariat's
mandate finally Mr President I would
like to reiterate Iran's clear and
consistent position on the conflict in
Ukraine
since the beginning of the conflict
Iran has maintained a position of active
neutrality and has emphasized that all
U.N member states must fully respect the
purpose and principles enshrined in the
United Nations Charter as well as
international law including sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
integrity
irons consistently advocate for peace
and immediate and to the Ukraine
conflict despite bilateral defense
cooperation agreement
Iran has never provided the parties with
weapons for use in the Ukraine conflict
either before or after the contribution
aside from the legal and political
position
Iran believes
from a moral point of view that
providing Military Support could not be
intended to end the war
but rather to escalate it increasing
damage and destruction and causing more
suffering for civilians that that is why
Iran has urged the parties to uphold
their obligations under the
international humanitarian law and
conduct consultations to protect
civilians and critical infrastructure
from military targets or attacks against
that background my delegation rejects
totally all unfounded allegations made
against my country at this meeting by
certain State I thank you Mr President
Republic of Iran for that statement
is